c'est curieux de constater construit ici
aujourd'hui parce qu'on devait être sur
le site d'un pacte le parc des sept
chutes qui a été fermé en janvier par
hydro québec sous prétexte de
d'austérité et de mesures de restriction
budgétaire je suis serge couturier
j'suis bien le juste la faune
spécialisée dans la grande faune les
réductions budgétaires pour un petit
ministère comme le mystère
l'environnement où le ministère de la
faune c'est des réductions qui peuvent
empêcher de réaliser le suivi des
espèces faune et que le rétablissement
des espèces menacées
on donne beaucoup beaucoup d'importance
au développement économique c'est bien
c'est un objectif louable mais quand le
développement économique se fait de
façon non soutenu que l'environnement ne
peut plus supporter par exemple le
niveau d'exploitation des forêts
bon là on a un problème on a un problème
non seulement parce que la conservation
de certaines espèces comme le caribou
forestier vont être mises en danger mon
un problème aussi pour la pérennité de
l'exploitation elle même on peut pas
continuer à exploiter la forêt et les
autres écosystèmes de façon abusive cdrs
qui vont qui vont nous suivre à long
terme donc pour des intérêts économiques
à court terme 1 1 2 1 on met en péril la
qualité de l'environnement à long terme
les intérêts économiques doivent
s'ajuster à la réalité de
l'environnement et non le contraire